[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Christian Sievers in allen
guten Abend dass ich Verhandlungen
quälend lange ziehen hat manchmal auch
schlicht mit Folklore zu tun allein über
die schiere Dauer will jede Seite zeigen
wir sind bis an unsere Grenzen gegangen
die Bund ländergespräche heute beim
Kanzler dauerten gut sechs Stunden die
Gründe sind diesmal andere erstens
konnten sich beide Seiten vorher nicht
mal darauf einigen wer überhaupt mit
korrekten Zahlen argumentiert und
zweitens geht es um nichts weniger als
die Zukunft der deutschen
Flüchtlingspolitik jetzt gibt es ein
Ende der Gespräche aber absehbar wohl
kein Ende der Diskussion der
flüchtlingsgipfel zumindest ist so eben
vorbei da konnte er Benji verfolgt ihn
für uns in Berlin guten Abend mit
welchem Ergebnis
ja es gibt tatsächlich ein gemeinsames
Ergebnis und das ist ja etwas
überraschend weil es bis zuletzt dann
doch so außer als ob sich beide Seiten
mit Maximalforderungen aufeinander zu
bewegen da gab es heute Unterbrechungen
in der in der gemeinsamen Sitzung da hat
man sich noch mal einen kleinen Gruppen
zusammengesetzt und sich dann
offensichtlich aufeinander zu bewegt und
das wichtigste Ergebnis aus Sicht der
Länder und der Kommunen dürfte sein dass
der Bund für 2023 noch einmal eine
Milliarde Euro für die
flüchtlingsversorgung in den Kommunen
dazu gibt zu dem was ohne hinzugegeben
hat und Olaf Scholz hat sich vorhin in
der Pressekonferenz die jetzt gerade
noch läuft schon mal sehr zufrieden
darüber geäußert dass beide Seiten die
Leistungen anerkannt haben gegenseitig
dass der Bund eine Menge schon an Kosten
Schulter hat und von andere Seite dass
die Kommunen aber auch unter besonderer
Belastung stehen das ist eine
Gemeinsamkeit die man hier
herausarbeiten konnte da gibt's aber
auch noch einen wichtigen Punkt über die
reine Finanzierung hinaus und da hat der
Bundeskanzler auf der Presse Konferenz
gerade eben folgendes gesagt
wichtigste Veränderung wird sein dass
Deutschland jetzt ganz neue Arten von
migrationspartnerschaften abschließen
wird wir werden uns mit anderen Ländern
verständigen über die Möglichkeit der
Erleichterung des Fachkräfte Zuges aus
diesen Ländern aber im Gegenzug eben
auch sehr klare Vereinbarungen
abschließen über die Rücknahme der
eigenen Staatsbürger wenn Sie hier nicht
bleiben können aus den verschiedenen
Gründen aber zum Beispiel auch deshalb
weil sie nicht erfolgreich sich hier um
zum Beispiel Asyl bemüht haben damit das
gut und effektiv und effizient gelingt
haben wir auch ein Sonderbeauftragten
Joachim Stand ist dafür jetzt von der
Bundesregierung benannt und hat sich
gleich beherzt und seine Arbeit gemacht
das wird als Vorhaben von Bund und den
Ländern gemeinsam geteilt und wird bei
der gemeinsame Herausforderung wir
kriegen wir jemanden der
ausreisepflichtig ist auch tatsächlich
dazu dass er wieder in seinen Heimatland
zurückkehrt sehr helfen
wir sind uns auch einig darüber dass es
notwendig ist dass wir den Schutz der EU
Außengrenzen weiter
voranbringen dass es etwas was nicht in
Deutschland stattfindet denn Deutschland
liegt mitten in Europa ist umgeben von
vielen anderen europäischen
Mitgliedstaaten unserer Union und ist
deshalb ein Land das interessiert ist an
einem effizienten Grenzschutz der aber
anderswo stattfindet und deshalb sind
wir unterstützend tätig mit unseren
eigenen Beamten und Beamten deshalb und
unterstützen wir das Vorhaben der
Europäischen Union diese Länder bei der
Errichtung von grenzschutzstrukturen zu
unterstützen und natürlich geht es auch
darum dass wir an der Grenze bessere
Möglichkeiten haben auf
asylanerkennungsverfahren direkt an den
EU-Außengrenzen durchzuführen
sagt der Bundeskanzler gerade eben in
Berlin also Schutz der EU-Außengrenzen
voranbringen Asylverfahren auch an den
EU-Außengrenzen stattfinden lassen das
sind ja chakunterla ja Ideen die schon
viele andere versucht haben in der
Vergangenheit können wir uns denn da
jetzt aus deutscher Sicht und für
Deutschland auf eine ganz neue
flüchtlings- und Asylpolitik einstellen
also der Ansatz bei den
migrationsabkommen der ist tatsächlich
mit einem eigenen beauftragten dafür
doch ein neuer da muss man aber dann
wirklich sehen was es im einzelnen auch
bringt bei den Verhandlungen die müssen
erst einmal ausgehandelt werden
insgesamt kann man nach dieser
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit dem
Bundeskanzler sagen dass zumindest
gelungen ist das alle mal unterschrieben
haben dass man sich in eine gemeinsame
Richtung bewegt eben mehr EU Außenschutz
außengrenzschutz und mehr Anstrengungen
bei einer Reform der gemeinsam das
gemeinsame europäischen Asylverfahrens
aber damit ist die Diskussion jetzt eben
noch nicht beendet alle sind sich auch
einig dass das keine direkten
Auswirkungen haben wird auf die Zahl der
Schutzsuchenden die nach Europa und dann
auch nach Deutschland kommen und
deswegen wird die Diskussion auch
weitergehen Stefan weil der
Ministerpräsident von Niedersachsen hat
gerade eben in der Pressekonferenz
darauf hingewiesen die Milliarde für die
für die Kommunen die wir vorhin am
Anfang schon erwähnt haben die wird das
Grundproblem nicht lösen man wird sich
im November noch einmal zusammensetzen
und dann noch einmal darüber reden
welche Hilfe Länder und Kommunen
dauerhaft brauchen bis dahin soll eine
Arbeitsgruppe weitere Schritte konkrete
Schritte erarbeiten
herzlichen Dank für diese blitzanalyse
sozusagen unmittelbar nach dem Ende des
flüchtlingsgipfels in Berlin und dann
gucken wir doch in die Politik direkt
der CDU Ministerpräsident von Hessen ist
bei uns live im heute journal Boris rein
guten Abend Herr Ministerpräsident
ja guten Abend sie haben heute den
ganzen Tag mehr als sechs Stunden mit
ihren Kolleginnen und Kollegen und den
Bundeskanzler zusammengesessen wir haben
jetzt gerade gehört es gibt eine ja eine
Grundsatzentscheidung die allerdings
vertagt wurde erstmal auf Ende des
Jahres es gibt aber jetzt kurzfristig
eine Milliarde mehr vom Bund für sie
reicht das
in der Tat so dass wir ja heute seit 38
schon zusammen saßen mit den
Ministerpräsidenten gemeinsam im Kreise
und dann ab 15 Uhr mit dem Bundeskanzler
es war sachlich es war konstruktiv aber
in der Tat waren lange Verhandlungen ich
finde das Ergebnis ist vertretbar wir
sitzen ja hier als Anwalt der Kommunen
und Handeln hier für die Kommunen der
Bundeskanzler ist nach sehr langem
Zögern bereite das Geld aufzustocken in
der Tat noch mal eine Milliarde auf die
bereits zugesagten Gelder für 2023 aus
meiner Sicht gibt es aber ein viel
wichtigeres Ergebnis nämlich dass die
Bundesregierung anerkennt dass sie
Finanzierung dieser Situation eine
dauerhafte Aufgabe von bunte Ländern und
Kommunen ist das ist schon mal gut aber
wir haben uns natürlich mehr gewünschten
deswegen müssen wir dringend weiter im
Gespräch sein mit der Bundesregierung ja
vorher hieß es aus von Seiten der Länder
wir brauchen eine dauerhafte
verlässliche zusätzliche Finanzierung
des Bundes jetzt gibt es eine einmalige
zusätzliche Finanzierung dauerhaft und
verlässlich ist das doch noch nicht sie
haben eigentlich das Problem nur wieder
vor sich hin geschoben
nein vor uns hingeschoben nicht sondern
in der Tat ist es genauso wie sie sagen
es sieht was wir brauchen ein atmendes
System und das heißt je mehr kommen
desto mehr Geld muss der Bund in die
Hand nehmen aber natürlich auch die
Länder und je weniger kommen desto
weniger ist notwendig das nenne ich mal
atmen des System wir wollen eigentlich
zurück zu unserem guten alten vier
Säulensystem der Bund will das so nicht
und deswegen haben wir gesagt jetzt
müssen wir mal die Dinge zusammenführen
das tun jetzt das tut ihr seine
Arbeitsgruppe in den nächsten fünf
Wochen im bis in den Juno hinein und
dann werden wir final und endgültig mit
dem bundem überhaupt über genau dieses
Thema dann verhandeln im November das
finde dann unter ähm hessischen
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz Vorsitz
statt also unter ihrem Vorsitz jetzt hat
ihn der Bund im Zuge dieser ganzen
Diskussion aber auch ganz konkrete
Hausaufgaben ins Stammbuch geschrieben
sozusagen unter anderem die ähm ja die
Gerichtsverfahren wenn also Asylsuchende
klagen dann dauern das kann man in der
Statistik nachlesen die Verfahren in
Deutschland im Schnitt 26 Monate also
über zwei Jahre in Hessen herein bei
ihnen dauern sie
33,9 Monate also fast drei Jahre da
müssen auch sie noch richtig
Hausaufgaben machen oder
ja nun ist es ja im föderalen System
nicht so dass der Bund den Ländern
Hausaufgaben gibt sondern die Länder
bilden den Bund aber wichtig ist lassen
wir mal die Formulierungen
mit den Hausaufgaben aber die ist ja
offensichtlich im Magen oder
ja genau da ist natürlich was im Hagen
und deswegen haben wir diese Gefahr
erkannt und wir haben sofort gehandelt
wir haben jetzt im Haushalt im
Doppelhaushalt
2023/2024 fast 500 neue Stellen für die
Justiz geschaffen in Hessen um genau
solche Situationen besser in den Griff
zu bekommen ich will noch einen Punkt
sagen der auch wichtig ist den wir heute
besprochen haben der Bund hat endlich
erkannt nach langer langer Zeit dass er
Migration besser steuern und
insbesondere begrenzen muss
beispielsweise Grenzsicherung
beispielsweise Aufstockung von frontext
beispielsweise dran sitzen drin viele
andere Themen spielen hier auch eine
Rolle die aus meiner Sicht ganz wichtig
sind ich ähm wir werden Ihnen begleiten
den Bund dabei und wir werden hier
unterstützen dabei ich hoffe aber dass
die Ampel sich in dieser Frage nicht
einmal mehr zerstreitet und ich hoffe
auch dass im die Bundesregierung bekommt
auf europäischer Ebene beispielsweise
Italien und Griechenland ja in dieser
Frage hinter deutlich zu bekommen und
ich hoffe sehr dass auch die
Gesetzgebungsverfahren in dieser Frage
jetzt schleunig vorangebracht werden im
Deutschen Bundestag herein Aufnahme und
Betreuung von Schutzsuchenden ist
Ländersache jetzt gehen wir ja schon
wieder in eine Situation in der wir in
den nächsten Monaten wahrscheinlich mit
der Diskussion weitermachen werden mit
vielen Arbeitsgruppen und am Ende
nochmal neuen Gesprächen sie pochen auf
das was Ländersache ist was ur ihr
ureigenstes Gebiet ist ja in allen
möglichen Fällen immer ganz penibel so
gesehen ist das was der Bund ja aktuell
macht immer eine extra Hilfe haben sie
mal überlegt diese gesamte
Struktur der flüchtlingsunterstützung
komplett an den Bund abzugeben
dann wäre noch aus ihrer Sicht alle
Probleme gelöst oder
ja ich weiß es ist aber nun mal unsere
Struktur und im Föderalismus ist die
Aufgabenverteilung so ich weiß auch gar
nicht ob es dann besser würde
wichtig ist für uns beispielsweise muss
ich vorstellen wir haben rund 50 Prozent
derer die hier sind und Asyl beantragt
haben haben eben kein Recht hier zu sein
haben kein Anspruch hier zu sein und
müssen zurückgeführt werden auch das ist
länderaufgabe keine Frage aber die
Voraussetzungen dass die Heimatländer
diese Leute wieder aufnehmen sie sind ja
dafür dazu völkerrechtliche verpflichtet
muss natürlich der Bund schaffen
beispielsweise durch den Visa Hebel
beispielsweise durch die Kürzung von
Entwicklungshilfe beispielsweise durch
die Kürzung von Wirtschaftshilfen das
muss der Bund jetzt auch anpacken
international und auch da hoffe ich dass
wir schneller voran kommen jetzt okay
also die Zusammenarbeit zwischen Bund
und Ländern die werden wir weiter genau
verfolgen müssen Boris rein der
Ministerpräsident von Hessen ich danke
Ihnen für das Gespräch danke schön
ja danke sie was tschüss nach Berlin so
und dann gucken wir jetzt auf die
Menschen die selbst auf dem Gipfel in
Berlin nicht vertreten sind über die
heute so viel geredet wird und die all
das natürlich sehr direkt betrifft denen
geht es interessanterweise ähnlich wie
den Streitparteien in Ländern und Bund
auch sie verzweifeln an der deutschen
Asylpolitik und insbesondere ihren
quälendlangen Wartezeiten die für sie
ein Leben in der Schwebe bedeuten dieser
Jan die hat in Berlin mit geflüchteten
gesprochen
Ankunft Berlin Tegel auf dem ehemaligen
Flugfeld ist eine Zeltstadt entstanden
Notunterkunft für fast 3.000 Menschen
aus der Ukraine in den Hallen
Leichtbauwände mit Vorhängen wandern
Wand rund 12 Personen schlafen zusammen
pro Kabine in einer davon bereitet ulena
marussenko den 14 Geburtstag ihrer
Tochter vor sie lebt seit Monaten mit
ihren Kindern ihren Tegel
wir sind zu viert seit vier Monaten
gehen die Kinder nicht mehr zur Schule
wir fühlen uns in Tegel gar nicht gut
man könnte sogar sagen sehr schlecht
ein Flughafen umfunktioniert zum
ankunftszentrum für geflüchtete aus der
Ukraine rund 50 kommen aktuell pro Tag
Tegel sollte Durchgangsstation sein ein
Dach und ein Bett für ein paar Tage nur
inzwischen bleiben die Menschen hier
Monate lang so auch Albina Hessen ja und
ihre Kinder
fünfeinhalb Monate sind wir hier das
schwierigste ist dass es zu viele
Menschen sind es ist sehr laut so lange
hier zu sein ist schrecklich
als der großen Probleme ist die fehlende
Selbstbestimmtheit wir haben hier feste
Zeiten wie das Licht an und ausgeht weil
wir das einfach zentralregeln müssen das
geht nicht anders wir arbeiten
selbstverständlich hier im Bereich der
Verhinderung vor der Abwendung von
Obdachlosigkeit niemand von uns möchte
gerne dass Menschen so leben Hallen die
nicht gewährleisten können als
Obdachlosigkeit zu verhindern doch was
kommt da Berlin rechnet in diesem Jahr
mit weiteren 10 bis 12.000 geflüchteten
doch schon jetzt sind nur noch wenige
hundert Plätze frei in regulären
Unterkünften der Stadt wir gehen davon
aus dass Tegel spätestens im August voll
ist dass wir dann keine
Unterkunftsmöglichkeiten mehr haben und
müssen anfangen andere Alternativen zu
entwickeln wo wir die Leute und wie wir
die Leute unterbringen möchten auf dem
Gelände des ehemaligen Flughafens
Tempelhof stehen schon Container ein
stadtsta dringt um Flächen und Gelder
insgesamt gab Berlin im letzten Jahr
rund 943 Millionen Euro für geflüchtete
aus rund 213 Millionen davon erstattete
der Bund inzwischen stehen auch in den
Hangars Container in denen Asylbewerber
vor allem aus Syrien der Türkei
Afghanistan leben
ali ist aus Kabul geflohen jeden Morgen
erwacht er mit deutschen Vokabeln neben
seinem Bett und hat Ziele
[Musik]
will ein Ausbildung machen
Menschen mit großen Hoffnungen in die
Zukunft in einer Stadt die jeden Tag
darum bringt ihnen überhaupt ein Dach
über dem Kopf zu bieten
jetzt in seiner bei uns der da ganz
unmittelbar gefordert ist vor Ort der
mein kinzig-kreis ist Hessens größter
Landkreis nach Einwohnern Thorsten stolz
SPD ist der
Landrat guten Abend Herr stolz
hallo wunderschönen guten Abend nach
Mainz sie rufen schon länger nach Hilfe
interessanterweise nicht nur beim Bund
auch bei ihrer Landesregierung die sie
jetzt sogar verklagt haben weil sie mit
der Verteilung von Flüchtlingen nicht
einverstanden sind jetzt haben sie ihre
Ministerpräsidenten ja gerade eben hier
bei uns gehört wird jetzt alles besser
ja wollen wir schauen ob alles
tatsächlich einfach auch besser wird
zunächst erstmal zu den zu den
Ergebnissen dass ich jetzt heute so
mitbekommen habe ich glaube ich erstmal
gut dass es überhaupt ein Ergebnis gibt
und ich will es auch mal ein Stück weit
so bezeichnen ein Zwischenergebnis rund
um den flüchtlingsgipfel in Berlin weil
es war schon meine persönliche
Erwartungshaltung und ich glaube der
spreche ich für die kommunale Familie
insgesamt dass ich jetzt endlich bunt
und auch die Länder zusammengerauft
haben auch ihren ersten großen Streit
erst einmal beigelegt haben und das ist
jetzt erste Ergebnisse gibt wo ich sage
das geht im Grunde nachher schon mal in
die richtige Richtung nämlich
Unterstützung und auch Entlastung der
kommunalen Familie der Städte der
Gemeinde und eben auch der Landkreise
insgesamt in Deutschland
aber ja jetzt kommt das aber das hören
wir uns noch an ja
genau wichtig ist aber jetzt auch dass
diese eine Milliarde auch wirklich eins
zu eins dann vom Bund über die
Bundesländer auch an die Kommunen und
somit an die Städte Gemeinde an die
Landkreisen eben auch eins zu eins
weitergeleitet wird das ist jetzt das
entscheidende Ausrufezeichen okay dann
parke ich da gleich mit einem
Fragezeichen ein sie unterstellen quasi
auch ihrem Land Hessen das ist quasi
selbst zwischendurch noch mal die Hand
aufhält und eben die Gelder vom Bund
nicht direkt an Sie weiterleitet oder
habe ich das falsch verstanden
das haben sie im Grunde nach richtig
verstanden aber das ist überhaupt keine
Unterstellung sondern das ist die
Erfahrung aus 2022 und aus 2023 denn wir
hatten in 2022 hat der Bund ja sehr
schnell reagiert und zusätzliche Gelder
zur Verfügung gestellt insbesondere für
die für geflüchteten aus der Ukraine und
er hat beispielsweise erst das Land
Hessen kurz vorm Jahreswechsel
2022-23 dann zumindest erstmal 70% der
Bundesgelder an die kommunale Familie
weitergeleitet aber nachdem wir richtig
Druck aufgebaut haben über die
kommunalen Spitzenverbände hier in
Hessen und in 2023 wurde bislang
signalisiert lediglich 50% der
Bundesmittel an die kommunale Familie
weiterzugeben und deswegen werden sie
verstehen wenn ich jetzt dort an der
Stelle sage dass die Erwartungen
wirklich der kommunalen Familie in Gänze
deutschlandweit aber natürlich auch im
Bundesland Hessen die ist die
Bundesmittel eins zu eins weiterleiten
interessant wieder auf dem auf dem Weg
des Geldes dann doch einiges verloren zu
gehen scheint Herr stolz eine Frage habe
ich noch ist denn das ganze wir reden
jetzt in den letzten Tagen sehr viel
über Finanzen sehr viel über Geld ist
das wirklich nur eine Frage der
Finanzierung oder verdecktes nicht im
Grunde genommen ganz grundlegende
Probleme der deutschen Asylpolitik
also es ist ja nicht nur eine Frage ist
eigentlich schon richtig der der Frage
der Finanzierung sondern wir haben dem
Kunde nach drei große Bausteine wo wir
sagen aus der kommunalen Ebene müssen
drei Dinge Dinge passieren Nummer eins
fangen wir ganz oben an auf der
europäischen Ebene wir brauchen eine
eine faire eine gerechte Verteilung von
geflüchteten von Asylsuchenden insgesamt
in Europa das sind jetzt erste Ansätze
da genauso ist es notwendig Menschen die
in der Bundesrepublik überhaupt keine
Bleibeperspektive haben dann einfach
auch sehr sehr zügig in ihrer
Heimatländer wieder einfach auch
zurückzuführen das sind die Dinge die
ganz oben stattfinden müssen und Nummer
zwei das ist glaube ich auch sehr
wichtig Stichwort Wohnraum die
Unterbringung die vernünftige Versorgung
von von Menschen das kann man alles
nicht nur immer mit der eins zu eins auf
die kommunale Ebene abwälzen deswegen
sagen wir auch von der kommunalen Seite
her es ist wichtig dass der Bund
ebenfalls zusätzliche
unterbringungskapazitäten schafft und
die Bundesländer ihre beginnenden
Kapazitäten tatsächlich erweitern also
es ist auch ein Thema der Versorgung der
Unterbringung und man muss hier
fairerweise sagen wir sind vom Thema
Integration weit entfernt das wird über
überhaupt nicht momentan in den Fokus
genommen es geht ja nicht nur um eine
Unterbringung eine Versorgung sondern am
Ende auch eine Integration der Menschen
und der dritte große Baustein ist eben
das Thema dauerhafte Entlastung
finanzieller Natur dort der Städte und
Gemeinden der Landkreise der kommunalen
Familie weil wir tragen hier vor Ort die
Hauptlast ja in organisatorischer
logistischer personeller und
finanzieller Hinsicht und da dürfen wir
weiter nicht wie Bittsteller behandelt
werden das ist der Appell einer Stimme
von vor Ort Thorsten stolz SPD Landrat
des Main-Kinzig-Kreises vielen Dank für
das Gespräch
ganz herzlichen Dank
so und jetzt hier in der Sendung die
Nachrichtenübersicht und Gundula du
beginnst da mit der Lage in der Ukraine
dort dauern die schweren Kämpfe vor
allem um bachmut an dabei hat das
ukrainische Militär nach eigenen Angaben
eine ganze Brigade der russischen
Truppen in die Flucht geschlagen damit
wären gleich lautende Angaben des Chefs
der russischen wagnergruppe prigoshi
bestätigt obwohl tausende russische
Soldaten aus der Region geflohen sein
bleibe die Lage in bachmo schwierig
erklärte ein ukrainischer
Militärsprecher in der Nähe von bachmut
ist außerdem ein französischer
Journalist bei einem Raketenangriff
getötet worden
in Israel nimmt die Gewalt nach dem
jüngsten Militärschlag gegen militante
Palästinenser wieder deutlich zu die
Zahl der Todesopfer ist auf 21 gestiegen
nach israelischen Medienberichten wurden
mehr als 200 Raketen aus dem
Gazastreifen auf Israel abgefeuert auch
in Tel Aviv gab es Luftalarm der von
Israel als Terrororganisation
eingestufte islamische Jihad hatte mit
Vergeltung gedroht nachdem drei seiner
Anführer gestern vom israelischen
Militär getötet worden waren
auf der tunesischen Insel Djerba sind
bei einem Angriff auf eine Synagoge
während eines jüdischen festes fünf
Menschen getötet worden 9 weitere wurden
verletzt bei dem Angreifer soll es sich
um einen tunesischen Nationalgardisten
Handeln nachdem er willkürlich um sich
geschossen haben soll wurde er von
Sicherheitskräften getötet die Synagoge
lagriba war bereits 2002 Ziel eines
Anschlags bei dem damals 19 Touristen
starben darunter 14 deutsche
nach dem zivilrechtlichen Urteil gegen
Donald Trump hat seinen Anwalt Berufung
angekündigt der frühere US-Präsident
hatte die Vorwürfe zurückgewiesen und
bezeichnete das Urteil als Schande ein
New Yorker Gericht hatte Trump gestern
des sexuellen Missbrauchs und
Verleumdung einer Schriftstellerin für
schuldig befunden und ihn zu einer
Geldstrafe von 5 Millionen Dollar
verurteilt strafrechtlich sind die
Vorwürfe die sich auf das Jahr 1996
beziehen verjährt
ich habe entschieden dass Patrick
reichen wegen dieses Fehlers nicht gehen
muss den Satz hat
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck
heute gesagt nach einer Befragung durch
Abgeordnete Patrick reichen das ist
einer von harbex-staatssekretärin der
mitentschieden hatte sein eigener
Trauzeuge bekommt den Top-Job bei einer
bundeseigenen Energieagentur nicht nur
wegen dieser Personalie ist Hawk seit
Tagen in der Kritik und deshalb kam
seinen Satz heute auch nicht bei allen
gut an die Opposition fordert dass der
Staatssekretär entlassen wird Patrizia
Wiedemeier
ja er habe einen Fehler gemacht und
bedauere diesen sehr mit diesem
Bekenntnis kam Staatssekretär Graichen
heute an der Seite von
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck in dem
Bundestag deutlich länger als geplant
wurden sie befragt reichen erklärt dass
er sich aus der Findungskommission hätte
zurückziehen müssen als klar war dass
sein Trauzeuge Michael Schäfer sich auf
die Stelle bei der Dehner beworben habe
reichen bedauert heute Habeck steht zu
ihm und Schäfer verzichtet auf die
Stelle
kaum war die Befragung beendet allen die
Unionsvertreter vor die Pressewand
beschweren sich dass die Sitzung nicht
öffentlich war weiter kommt Julia
Klöckner erstmal nicht ein paar Meter
weiter beginnt Robert Habeck sein
Statement wem die mediale Aufmerksamkeit
gilt war klar dann warten wir gerade sie
Zeichen gerade auf alles für heute schon
sonst wie
Robert habe Weg stellt sich erneut
hinter seinen Staatssekretär hält noch
an ihm fest auch wenn dieser gegen die
Compliance Regeln verstoßen hat noch
werde geprüft Habeck warnt vorschnellen
Urteilen ich habe entschieden das
Fahrzeug reichen wegen dieses vieles
nicht gehen muss und die Debatte eben im
Ausschuss
gibt mir
meine ich eine gewisse Hoffnung dass die
Differenzierung
diese Entscheidung auch klarer
verständlich macht für Harbeck sind
damit alle Fragen beantwortet der Fall
erledigt die Opposition dagegen die
jetzt endlich zu Wort kommt hat höchste
Zweifel an der Eignung der
Staatssekretärs reichen für seinen
Posten fordert weitere Untersuchungen es
wurde häufig auch vom Minister davon
gesprochen es wurden Fehler gemacht es
gibt einen Unterschied zwischen
menschlichem Fehler unterlaufen uns
allen aber so lapidar die Vorgänger als
Fehler abzutun halten wir für falsch und
so nutzte die Opposition die
anschließende aktuelle Stunde als
Generalabrechnung mit Harbeck alles
wurde vermischt die Themen Trauzeuge
Vettern Wirtschaft heizungsgesetz
wärmewende jetzt schlägt der Heizungs-
Superminister plus Superman gleich super
Chaos von Ethos haben Sie wahrscheinlich
noch nie etwas gehört um Werte Vertrauen
Glaubwürdigkeit und das geht es in der
Politik und das haben sie maßlos
beschädigt für die Redner der Ampel
dagegen ist das Thema geklärt und
erledigt wir haben große
Herausforderungen gerade im
Wirtschaftsklima und energieressort wir
können es uns schlichtweg nicht erlauben
uns wochenlang mit selten mit uns selbst
zu beschäftigen wir können froh sein
dass Robert Habeck und Patrick reichen
in Verantwortung gewesen sind und das
Land gut durch den letzten Winter
gebracht haben das Thema ist geklärt die
richtigen Schlüsse wurden rausgezogen
wir werden weiter dafür sorgen dass die
Energieversorgung erstens gesichert wird
und zweitens klimaaneutral ist doch am
Ende der Debatte bleibt die Stimmung
geladen Habeck stellt Tilman Koban von
der CDU zur Rede der zuvor die
Entlassung reichens gefordert hat es
dürfte schwierig werden ein
heizungsgesetz durchzusetzen wenn weiter
so über den Fall reichen debattiert wird
das heutige Festhalten an seinem
Staatssekretär es könnte sich verhabig
noch als falsche Entscheidung erweisen
einige Turbulenzen heute auch bei VW
Gundula damit machst du jetzt weiter
ein kuchenangriff und ein nacktprotest
das hat es so auf einer Hauptversammlung
noch nicht gegeben der Volkswagenkonzern
wollte seinen Aktionären eigentlich
Fakten und Visionen präsentieren Valerie
Haller denn es gibt ja viele Baustellen
wie geht der noch neue Vorstand Oliver
Blume diese an ja er geht sie an mit
einem zehn Punkteplan der im Kern auf
Elektromobilität und das vernetzte Auto
abzielt Blume will und muss VW fit für
die Zukunft machen und hat auf dem Weg
dahin schon einiges zustimmen dass das
keine kuschel-veranstaltung werden würde
war von Anfang an klar schon früh flog
eine Torte in Richtung Bühne Proteste
auf Hauptversammlungen kommen vor auch
bei VW doch dieses Mal waren sie lauter
und auffälliger die Kritik zielt ab auf
den dieselskandal die
menschenrechtssituationen in China wo VW
stark vertreten ist und auf das
Kerngeschäft verbrennerautos auch
zurückhaltendere vw-aktionäre dürften
nicht zufrieden sein und nicht nur mit
dem seit Monaten mauenkurs vW droht in
China bei E-Autos den Anschluss zu
verlieren bei der Softwareentwicklung
hinkt der Autobauer der Konkurrenz
hinterher und die Kosten gelten als zu
hoch gute Software ist entscheidend
besonders in China der vielleicht
wichtigste Markt für deutsche Autobahn
dort zählen nicht so sehr Pferdestärken
sondern ob ein Autos smart und vernetzt
ist rund eine Milliarde Euro nimmt VW
für ein neues Innovationszentrum in
China in die Hand klingt nach viel
könnte für die Zukunft von VW aber
entscheidend sein vielen Dank nach
Frankfurt an Valeria
das Europa-Parlament hat mit großer
Mehrheit für die Ratifizierung der
sogenannten istanbul-konvention gestimmt
die Frauen Schutz vor Gewalt zu sichert
mehrere EU-Mitglieder wie Ungarn
Bulgarien und die baltischen Staaten
haben das Abkommen zwar noch nicht
gebilligt und die Türkei trat 2021
wieder aus aber mit dem heutigen
Beschluss soll es auch dort gelten
und hier fehlen noch die gewinnzahlen
vom Lotto am Mittwoch
sie lauten ohne Gewähr 10 14 23 25 44 49
Superzahl 8 weitere Gewinnzahlen auf
Lotto zdf.de und im zdf-text auf Seite
so wir verabschieden uns heute mit einem
wichtigen Hinweis gleich nach uns läuft
eine ganz besondere Doku ein Neonazi
Aussteiger gibt einen Einblick in
Waffenhandel und Umsturzpläne hier bei
uns in Deutschland um den Aussteiger von
möglichen Racheaktionen zu schützen
haben die Filme Macher ihn und die
Ereignisse über die er auspackt komplett
virtuell animiert das alles zu sehen ist
alarmierend und aufrüttelnd zugleich
hier nach uns im ZDF und morgen freuen
sich an dieser Stelle Maria Slomka und
Hanna Zimmermann auf sie und um 0:45 Uhr
meldet sich Christopher Wehrmann mit
unserem heute schon mal Update
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter wir haben es
regelrecht mit einer blockadesituation
zu tun das Hoch hier im Osten das
blockiert den Weg der Tiefs und so
müssen sie woanders hinausweichen zum
Beispiel nach Norditalien und hier
regnet es ergiebig gut 200 Liter auf den
Quadratmeter bis Sonntag sind punktuell
möglich das sind sehr große Regenmengen
auch bei uns regnet es aber nicht so
stark wie über Norditalien über dem
Osten Deutschlands ist es sogar komplett
trocken schauen wir uns die Details an
in der Nacht also im Osten trocken sonst
etwas Regen von Schleswig-Holstein bis
an die Alpen hier allerdings ergiebiger
Regen nach Westen hin bildet sich sogar
Nebel die Temperaturen gehen zurück auf
5 Grad an den Alpen im Nordosten sind es
zehn bis zwölf Grad morgen dann
weiterhin trocken und sonnig im Osten
Deutschlands ansonsten ist aber ging es
los von Schleswig-Holstein über die
Mitte bis an die alpenschauer und
Gewitter und hier an den Alpen regnet es
weiterhin ergiebig bei höchsten
Temperaturen von neun Grad dort ist es
am kühlsten 23 Grad im Osten
Deutschlands am wärmsten Blicke auf die
nächsten Tage Schauer und Gewitter
setzen sich fort im Norden im Osten mehr
Sonnenschein als sonst 14 bis 23 Grad ja
und auch das Wochenende sieht so ähnlich
aus damit ein schöner Abend